in a world where practically every
device interaction
or information exchange is generating
data making this data available
reliable and comprehensible becomes as
important as the insights they generate
and that is where data engineers come in
data engineers are the ones who step in
first and need to possess
a diverse skill set from understanding
diverse data sources to developing data
set processes
modeling and mining data and making it
ready for analysis
under cutting-edge data engineering
techniques what if you could possess
all of this and more in one single
rigorous online bootcamp in just
eight months welcome to simply learn's
postgraduate program
in data engineering in partnership with
purdue university
and in collaboration with ibm aligned
with aws
and microsoft azure certifications this
unique online bootcamp gets you
endorsement from all leading players
and you needn't even leave your home or
your job to get it
learn by doing gain work-ready expertise
in today's top big data tools and skills
including hadoop framework
data pipelines spark kafka big data on
aws
and azure cloud and more in an advanced
curriculum selectively designed with the
help of top minds in industry and
academia
immerse yourself in a high engagement
global boot camp with eight times higher
live interaction
14 plus real-life projects capstone and
three domains
master classes by purdue faculty and ibm
experts and ibm exclusive ask me
anything sessions
and at the end of these eight
game-changing months you'll add to your
resume a joint purdue simply learn
certification
and industry recognized ibm certificates
for the ibm courses in the learning path
and become a member in the coveted
purdue university alumni association
and emerge stronger more qualified and
worthy of top data engineering positions
in any cutting edge company with an
insane 50 percent
year-over-year growth data engineering
positions are on their highest flight
so should be your career fill out a
two-minute application form
and your personal admissions consultant
will be in touch with the prerequisites
we're excited to meet you at our next
cohort
you